l'on passe maintenant à notre débat le
second débat de sens public il est
volontairement décalée de l'actualité
gilles souvent que c'est un débat de
société alors là on est en plein dedans
puisque le quotidien le monde propose
depuis quelques jours sans reportages
réalisés dans toute la france
radiographie de la société française
dont on va débattre dans un instant mais
d'abord on est allé dans un quartier
multi facettes de paris on est dans le
quartier de belleville 20e
arrondissement illustration avec
guillaume bertrand derrière la lampe au
dessus tout en haut au dernier étage au
cinquième voilà je suis dénonce cible là
donc tu vois ça va faire ça fra 61 en
décembre et c'est justement dans cette
même rue que joseph pantaleo ouvre un
bistrot à l'âge de 30 ans ici le vieux
belleville fait figure de symbole du
quartier
j'ai acheté le bistrot
[Musique]
est depuis son bistrot jojo comme il se
fait appeler a vu son environnement
changer tout le monde se connaissait
dans le quartier tu vois je suis allé au
bistrot tu pouvais rencontrer
l'électricien pour rencontrer le pain
tout pouvait rencontrer le pompier fait
que me dit quand il arrivait au resto va
tout le monde était identique au monde
était pareil tandis que là et on voit un
petit peu des fois
un changement de comportement dans le
sens où maintenant on est obligé de
créer des animations comme les fêtes des
voisins par exemple les cités
bellevilloise et les logements sociaux
my le quartier on les trouve presque à
chaque coin de rue pour joseph c'est un
avantage précieux
ici on est entouré de cité c'est pas du
tout c'est pas du tout pénalisant ça
permet d'avoir vraiment un mélange
social sinon je pense que ce serait plus
difficile dans l'emblématique rue de
belleville longue de 350 numéro les
restaurants chinois populaire côtoient
les épiceries fines ou encore les
brasseries bretonne une diversité
nécessaire pour répondre à la demande de
consommateurs que tout semble opposer
cette agence immobilière identifie deux
types d'acheteurs bien différent vous
avez traditionnellement une clientèle
qui est plutôt populaire qui n'a pas
forcément des gros revenus mais depuis
quelques années on voit l'arrivée de
nouvelles catégories
socioprofessionnelles qui s'installe
qu'on n'aurait pas vu dans le secteur
c'est à dire des dirigeants
d'entreprises des cadres supérieurs des
gens qui travaillent plutôt du secteur
dans le secteur 8e arrondissement de
paris à ce qu'ils apprécient le côté
village le côté un peu un peu bobo de ce
secteur là la mode de belleville et
l'arrivée de ces nouveaux habitants plus
aisés ont fait grimper le prix de
l'immobilier qui varient ici de 9000 à
12500 euros le mètre carré même si la
tendance depuis un an et à la baisse de
tels tarifs exclut de facto les
acheteurs les plus modestes
la société française est-elle fracturé
une radiographie voilà ce que vous
propose pendant les 40 dernières minutes
de cette émission un petit peu moi ça
passe trop vite je vous présente mes
invités nicolas chapuis bonsoir bien
ensemble la directeur adjoint de la
rédaction du monde vous avez piloté ce
projet fragments de france qui nous a
donné envie tout simplement de réaliser
ce ce débat bienvenue avoue françoise
gatel bonsoir ça vous êtes sénatrice
union centriste d'ille-et-vilaine
président de la délégation sénatoriale
aux collectivités locales et à la
décentralisation
jérôme fourquet bienvenue politologue
directeur du département opinion à
l'ifop vous publiez avec jean-laurent
cassely la france sous nos yeux c'est
aux éditions du seuil et frédéric saiss
et toujours à mes côtés c'est compliqué
parce que à la fois dans le dossier le
projet du monde et dans votre dernier
livre c'est vraiment un kaléidoscope que
vous nous proposez les uns et les autres
donc nous on a choisi la ville parce que
c'est aussi un quartier en mutation
c'est intéressant j'ai une première
question pour vous jérôme fourquet sur
paris paris c'est un concentré de france
où c'est un monde à part alors on voit
dans votre reportage qui a un certain
nombre de tendances qu'on observe un peu
ce partout sur le territoire qu'on
retrouve bien évidemment à paris
notamment cette hybridation et cette
influence de la globalisation ne serait
ce qu'au plan gastronomique avec dans la
même rue des restaurants des quatre des
quatre coins du monde donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on aurait en commun
avec beaucoup d'autres territoires
ensuite et quand même des spécificité
parisienne qui sont très fortes le
reportage le monde ne serait ce que sur
le prix du mètre carré le prix de
l'immobilier alors d'autres métropoles
desservis par les tgv commence à voir
leur prix grimper aussi mais on est
quand même encore très loin de paris et
puis quelque chose sur lequel on revient
dans le livre qui nous a beaucoup frappé
c'est le caractère très singulier de
paris dans son rapport à la voiture
aujourd'hui il n'ya plus que 35% des
parisiens qui sont possesseurs d'une
automobile contre 85% de la population
française est donc là on voit beaucoup
dans la presse quotidienne régionale
mais pas seulement beaucoup d'articles
sur les prix du carburant
à paris on est relativement épargnée par
ce phénomène a donc une singularité
à la fois en termes de composition
sociale le prix du mètre carré est aussi
en termes de modes de vie il n'y a pas
si longtemps encore pompidou la bagnole
les voies sur berges etc etc paris
communion avec le reste de la france
dans le le mythe de la voiture de
voiture et qui sait elle s'en éloigne de
plus en plus la vision parisienne de
l'actualité nicolas chapuis est ce que
c'est aussi ce que vous vouliez dépassé
avec avec fragments de france oui bien
sûr c'est ce qu'on voulait dépasser
parce qu'on voulait raconter on voulait
raconter autre chose c'est patent
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe à paris que
la vision qu'ont les parisiens du reste
la france qu'on conduit parfois les
médias par fière d'elle les médias très
parisien évidemment et cette vision un
peu
pessimiste et caricaturale du reste de
la france qu'on peut avoir dans les
médias parisiens et ça qu'on voulait
dépasser on voulait essayer de raconter
autre chose et en envoyant en fait sans
journalistes à travers la france mais
aussi à paris parce qu'on a tenu à
raconter ce territoire eh ben on arriva
comme vous le disiez un kaléidoscope qui
est vraiment très très différents de
ceux de cette espèce de nuages de
pessimisme qu'on a à paris de ceux de
cette vision d'une france qui serait
déchiré d'une france qui serait
totalement fragmentée justement on l'a
pas appelé la france fragmenté ce projet
on l'a appelée fragments de france parce
que chacun des chacun des reportages et
un petit fragment raconte un bout d'un
grand tableau qui serait très complexe
de dire je pense que les gens qui sont
capables de dire aujourd'hui la france
est comme si vous la france est comme ça
son je sais pas comment ils font parce
que c'est un pays qui est vraiment très
complexe très nuancée où les choses que
j'ai commencé on dira d'ailleurs c'était
des choses sont très différents selon
les territoires et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui en plus avec la crise du
coc vite car battu énormément de choses
notre projet essayez de raconter la
france mais surtout il raconte un pays
qui est un peu à racontable d'apprendre
parce qu'il est très divers et très
nuancée je retiens le terme ce nuage de
pessimistes est-ce que vous rencontrez
vous avez ce sentiment là parfois quand
vous débarquez à paris pour quelques
jours pour les sessions parlementaires
ce décalage entre votre département et
ce pessimisme parisien est ce que vous
ressentez ça alors je tu penses nous on
parle beaucoup de pensées ou de vision
vertical sert quand de paris on se
penche sur la france on aimerait avoir
une vision un peu monolithique vous avez
parlé de fragments de france moi je
parle de morceaux de france et je ne
pense pas que la france soit en morceaux
par contre et qu'il faut un peu
recomposer le poste moi je pense que
quand on rentre dans les territoires
comme vous l'avez fait on voit des
initiatives
tout ça mais assez fabuleuse qu'elle
sait dire il ya des espèces de petits
mais rails dans des territoires où on
pourrait se dire c'est très triste et
très loin de tout non les gens inventent
des choses
parce que ils n'ont d'autre solution que
d'inventer des choses ce que des
territoires où les choses ne sont pas
donnés il y a un professeur un géographe
à la sorbonne s'appelle gérard françois
dumont il n'y a pas de fatalité dans les
territoires il faut que les territoires
trouvent ce qu'ils appellent leur génie
c'est à dire il ya un truc avec lesquels
autour duquel vous allez faire un avenir
et vous allez faire d'un projet alors
c'est compliqué c'est des micros choses
très souvent mais c'est fabuleux et ces
gens là ils n'ont pas le temps de
déprime et parce que il faut qu'ils
agissent donc ce sont des faiseurs ils
inventent des trucs mais parfois ça
absolument épatant
jérôme fourquet votre précédent livre on
trouve à celui qui avait frappé
l'opinion l'archipel français publiant
en 2019 vous décriviez l'atomisation
l'unité vacillant de notre société est
ce que vous dites france faire fracturer
et contrairement à nicolas chapuis une
certaine façon est ce que vous aller
jusque là alors il ya des forces de
rappel bien évidemment parler des
services publics à la française on a un
autre modèle social a parlé du coc vie
tout à l'heure on a vu que le quoi qu'il
en coûte s'était passé par là et qu'on
avait plutôt collectivement bien
traverser même si beaucoup de dégâts
mais plutôt bien traversé cette épreuve
et que par exemple les inégalités dont
on parle beaucoup en france contre on en
regarde les indicateurs internationaux
en france on se porte plutôt mieux que
deux dans d'autres pays vous avez parlé
toutes les initiatives locales le
maillage associatif
donc il ya des forces de rappel très
très puissante quand même qui permettent
à ces différentes îles et îlots de
l'archipel de ne pas trop dériver les
unes des autres néanmoins on a quand
même des singularités qui sont très
marqués je prends département comme le
vôtre l'ille-et-vilaine entre la
métropole rennaise où le littoral qui
bénéficie d'un dynamisme économique et
une qualité de vie tout à fait
exemplaire on a aussi des territoires
alors ils ont trouvé leur génie à vitré
ou avenue cheikh où il ya un dynamisme
économique très fort et puis des zones
rurales un peu enclavé du monday de
redon où c'est plus compliqué il sera
facturé au sein même d'un département
alors regardez sur paris regardez sur
paris c'est où le voit sur les prix du
mètre carré vous le voyez ou sur les
votes les votes d'une rue à l'autre on
passe de 70 % d'un vote de droite à 70%
d'un bloc de gauche dans certains
territoires donc il il ya ces éléments
de fragmentation qui sont quand même là
avec les forces de rappel qui permettent
à l'ensemble de tenir à peu près de bal
en bal en de donner encore bon ça ici il
ya un mot qui revient beaucoup dans dans
la boue des des candidats c'est le mot
réconciliation oui et d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas innocent quand on lit le
portrait que vous dressez de la france
il revient tout le temps chez beaucoup
d'entre les candidats en tout cas par
exemple on peut écouter yannick jadot le
candidat écologiste à la présidentielle
nous portons un grand une grande
réconciliation nationale mais autour de
cette écologique est la seule qui est le
seul logiciel qui nous permet
d'affronter le futur avec un peu de
sérénité l'écologie comme réconciliation
alors si on est mauvais esprit on peut
penser qu'il parle de son propre parti
la réconciliation avec la primaire où il
ya eu que la dissension mais non c'est
l'écologie et sens global qui peut
amener les français à espérer ensemble
il n'est pas le seul guillaume larrivé
députés lr parle aussi de cette
réconciliation il dit ça doit être le
premier objectif de ma famille politique
la droite au terme d'un quinquennat qui
étaient excessivement marquée par les
affrontements on pense bien sûr à la
crise des gilet jaune est d'ailleurs
emmanuel macron lors de la crise des
gilets jaunes en 2018 disait lui-même je
veux réconcilier la base et le sommet
s'était aussi son verbe alors le
problème de ce mot réconciliation
évidemment c'est qu'il est un peu vague
ce n'est pas un programme politique
c'est en blanc - une méthode ça peut
même passer un peu pour du consensus mou
et d'ailleurs certains candidats qui
sont davantage dans la revendication de
la radicalité l'utilisent pas ou peu on
n'a jamais entendu eric zemmour parler
de réconciliation lui fait le constat
d'une guerre civile mais dans un tout
autre genre
jean luc mélenchon qui revendique une
conflictualité des problèmes politiques
lui il n'utilise pas non plus ce mot de
réconciliation alors cela dit les deux
hommes passent par un autre terme ils
utilisent les sondages pour montrer que
leurs propositions sur le fond et si on
exclut la figure qui déporte sont
largement plébiscité augmentation du
smic pour jean luc mélenchon arrêt de
l'immigration nous dire examen pour
qu'ils obtiennent chacune 60 à 70 % dans
les sondages vous avez donc ce mode
réconciliation qui peut presque
illustrer un autre clivage politique
ceux qui veulent renverser la table d'un
côté et ceux qui veulent finalement
remettre le couvert de l'autre merci
pour cette analyse nicolas chapuis est
ce que cette enquête vous ne l'avez
aussi lancé un peu contre justement ce
constat d'une france au bord de la
guerre civile que qui a alimenté cette
cette campagne où cette pré campagne oui
c'est cette grande cette grande enquête
sans journal c'est sans photographe
envoyés sur le terrain elle a été lancée
pour deux choses 1 parce que on s'est
dit c'était en mai juin dernier à
l'époque on était dans un autre film
politique que celui d'aujourd'hui mais
un film dont on disait aussi qu'il était
déjà écrit c'était emmanuel macron face
à marine le pen au deuxième tour et et
c'était c'était pas la peine limite de
faire la campagne on pouvait déjà passé
à autre chose on voit aujourd'hui que
les choses ont bien changé et que
peut-être que le film qu'on nous dit
aujourd'hui n'est pas n'est pas écrit
non plus et on s'est dit oui ce film là
nous on n'est pas certain qu'il soit
déjà écrit et jade est revenu à la base
du et de deux ans a dit que quel
reportage exactement le partir d'une
campagne présidentielle avec un scénario
déjà écrit c'était la meilleure façon de
se planter tout simplement
journalistique mans et que quand on est
journaliste on part pas du constat du
présupposé de de l'opinion on part du
terrain on va voir sur le terrain ce qui
se passe et on part dans une société qui
à mon avis on ne mesure pas encore ce
qui a été la crise du coc vide on le
mesure en terme de crise sanitaire mais
en terme de crise sociale tout ce que ça
a détruit dans le pays et surtout tout
ce qui s'est aussi reconstruit à travers
à travers cette crise là et tous ces
changements là on est incapable
aujourd'hui de les mesurer si on va pas
sur le terrain si on va pas voir si on
fait pas la base notre métier à savoir
aller faire du reportage mais en son
temps ensuite viendra le temps de
l'analyse et le temps du commentaire de
la polémique on aura tout le temps tout
le temps pour ça dans la campagne mais
il nous était nous semblait nécessaire
de dire à nos lecteurs que s'il suivait
la campagne chez nous et bien il au rsa
en premier le reportage et terrain le
terrain les faits et finalement si vous
essayez de même si on l'a dit c'est un
kaléidoscope c'est ultra variés s'est
fragmenté au sein même d'un territoire
cette thématique de la guerre civile
elle vient spontanément et cité
absolument pas aucun aucun aucun
français qu'on a interrogés ben nott
neutre notre noces en reportage ne
présentent pas être exhaustif la série
française qui qu'ils peuvent ressentir
ça et les difficultés d'ailleurs ne sont
pas niés dans ces cent reportages liés à
la thématique de l'immigration qui est
présente la team la thématique de
l'insécurité mais il ya surtout beaucoup
d'autres thématiques qui intéressent les
français et qui ne sont pas génératrice
de guerre civile le premier le premier
sujet dont on parle tous les français
qu'on va interroger c'est celui du
pouvoir d'achat la question de
l'écologie et de cette peur qui vient de
ceux de ce mur qui vient est très
présente partout et puis surtout ils ont
beaucoup de thématiques de
préoccupations qui sont très différentes
et très local finalement ils ont leur
vie leur collision locales qui sont pour
eux parfois beaucoup plus importante que
les grandes questions géopolitiques de
nos temps et quand on voit cette
diversité cette cette multiplicité de
préoccupation on se dit que ceux qui
essayent de répondre par des caricatures
ou par des solutions toutes faites se
trompe très largement vous 04 juste pour
rebondir sur la question de la guerre
civile il est des images qui ont tourné
en boucle sur différentes chaînes ce
week-end c'est ce qui s'est passé en
marge d'un conférences meetings
d'eric zemmour à nantes on a un millier
ou 1500 personnes qui viennent écouter
le polémiste et puis on a six cent
cinquante personnes dehors qui
s'affrontent avec les forces de l'ordre
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir
dans lequel cadre ça se déroule c'est
une zone commerciale qu'on décrit dans
le livre comme il y en a tant à zenit
qui était construit à côté du parking de
la grande surface et l'écrasante
majorité des gens vous reporter ont dû
voir son sur ce parking en train de
pousser leurs caddies pendant que à
peine 2000 personnes mime une forme de
guerre civile donc il ya des minorités
qui sont extrêmement radicaliser
extrêmement mobilisés mais la grande
majorité de la population n'est pas dans
ce film on dans ce dans ce scénario là
elle existe et minorité il faut
évidemment il faut en parler mais il
faut pas il faut pas surestimer leur foi
c'est ce que vous ne les aurez
sensibilité de voir deux de vos
reportages tous que nous essayer aussi
de faire à notre niveau vous montrer
cette france silencieuse qui qui est un
peu par ce qui est souvent éloignée des
images ou très choc très martial qui
peuvent être qu'ils peuvent être montrés
essayer de ramener les choses à leur
proportion dans quelques centaines
d'individus serein une agglo comme celle
de nantes bon et puis on connaît la
tradition assez remuant de cet effet des
images
et on sait on sait où c'est leur
efficacité sur ie voyez vous parliez de
du regard paris province et par les
cantons province voient les samedis de
gilet jaune ou de manif anti passe en
impression que paris est à feu et à sang
alors ça a été le cas quelques samedi de
novembre décembre 2018 2019 mais ces
derniers mois à chaque fois ces deux à
trois mille personnes et donc
l'écrasante majorité du territoire
parisien est complètement exos
exonérations de
cotisations ou d'agitation françoise
gatel oui je pense à ce qu'il s'est
passé à nantes et jérôme fourquet l'a
dit julia ya quand même un milieu
assez prolifique en matière de rébellion
et de black blocks depuis l'aéroport
notre dame des landes et que on sait
bien que ils viennent à nantes et à
rennes et tout tout événement émotif à
se mobiliser et à donner des images de
guerre civile mais effectivement moi je
quand on entend les gens parlaient tout
ça ils ont l'impression que c'est très à
la marge que c'est un autrement et les
gens ils ont des questions qui sont les
leurs c'est comment j'ai accès à la
santé l'environnement vous avez raison
c'est un vrai sujet mais moi j'habite à
35 km de la ville comment je fais pour
aller pour aller travailler je ne peux
pas me loger dans les villes parce que
l'aco vide a eu un effet positif si je
puis dire c'est à dire elle a donné
envie à des gens de quitter les grandes
villes est donc dans mon département
divine même dans les toutes petites
communes il n'y a plus une maison de
centre bourg à acheter
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont eu envie
de venir habiter là pour trouver un
cadre de vie télétravailler ou que sèche
et donc il ya de plus en plus de gens
qui sont les autochtones du secteur ou
du département qui sont condamnés à
aller habiter plus loin c'est vrai dans
le littoral et donc les gens disent mais
moi comment je vais travailler comme
angers accès à la santé parce que ça
c'est un autre point d'achat gipa
aujourd'hui alors le pouvoir d'achat oui
et non si je puis dire parce qu'en même
temps on a des personnes qui se disent
c'est un peu compliqué pour moi mais moi
dans mon département sage le sens pas
trop sauf que la crise a fragilisé des
personnes c'est vrai que les gens ont
peur pour leurs enfants c'est à dire on
était dans une société où à chaque
génération prospérait ont prospéré un
niveau d'études et ont prospéré en
ressources financières
or aujourd'hui le modèle n'est plus
celui là et on voit des familles qui ont
à charge parfois des parents qui sont
âgés quand des petits de retraite et qui
en même temps ou à charge leurs enfants
et donc là on a une peur d'une peur de
l'avenir une peur de ne pas avoir assez
alors qu'en même temps on voit bien
qu'on a un taux de chômage qui est des
plus faibles mais que je pense qu'il y à
un mode de vie qui fait aussi sur le
pouvoir d'achat qu'il ya des attentes
qui sont importantes et quand le prix du
carburant augmente enfin on voit bien à
crier gilet jaune l'étincelle ça a été
ça donc ça c'est un vrai sujet moi je
pense que c'est là où il peut y avoir
une fracture de gens qui disent non mais
ils sont très gentilles l'écologie sauf
que moi je obligé d'avoir une voiture et
une des voitures parce que j'ai pas les
moyens donc les gens se sentent
culpabilisés et punis donc c'est voilà
tout ça c'est un peu un peu confirmé ce
que vous entendez dans le premier débat
par les de la la comme 26 à vous à ça
vous a aussi fait fait penser à ça non
monsieur je me fais cette réflexion mais
sans doute
absolument pas
vous parler des idées je les propose de
réécouter un extrait de discours du
président la république
où finalement les maquereaux ont décrit
les fractures françaises on est en train
de sens d'essayer de les analyser c'est
lors du grand débat y ait dans lot face
au maire on né le 18 janvier 2019
nous avons aujourd'hui une fracture
sociale qui est là tu disais ça fait
plus de vingt ans qu'on en parle c'était
la campagne de 1995 nous n'avons pas
réglé qui a une fracture territoriale
qui s'est installée et qui a été le fait
d'une accélération
du cours du monde d'énergie c'est plus
en plus concentrée dans les métropoles
c'est un phénomène qu'on ne voit pas
qu'en france d'ailleurs
il ya une fracture écologiques et
environnementales qui est en train de
s'installer
elle vient doublonner la fracture
sociale mais elle vient aussi fracturé
beaucoup de territoires dont l'activité
dépend d'une mobilité qui a besoin de
consommer des maîtres d'agréer
d'agriculture d'industrie et donc ça
aussi c'est quelque chose qu'on doit
pouvoir appréhender et puis d'une
fracture démocratique avec laquelle vous
avez terminé qui elle aussi ne remonte
pas à hier donc on est en janvier 2019
on est en pleine crise ddj les jaunes
geron pour qu est ce qu elle pourrait
redémarrer vous deux voilà de ce que
vous avez
sont d observer comment vous analysé
cette perspective c'est pas facile de
répondre à leur foi est prudent et
modeste puisqu'il a pas grand monde qui
avait vu surgir la liste des gilets
jaunes donc on a maintenant oui un adage
qui dit que l'histoire passe rarement
les plats
donc on a un niveau des prix du
carburant s'était rappelée qui est plus
haut que celui que qui avait déclenché
la crise à l'orgue à crise avait été
aussi déclenché à la fois par le prix
mais par l'annoncé d'une taxe il y avait
une dimension en tout cas au début qui
était très anti taxe qui était très
forte alors qui peut rejaillir
aujourd'hui puisque on taxe encore
beaucoup les carburants en france mais à
l'heure où on se parle on ne voit pas
mais soyons quand une fois modeste les
prémices d'un d'une saison 2
ddd gilet jaune peut-être pour deux
raisons ou trois raisons
la première c'est que il ya quand même
une réponse gouvernementale même si
d'aucuns estiment que c'est pas assez il
ya quand même eu le chèque énergie sur
toute une partie de la population pour
la facture de gaz et d'électricité il ya
le chèque de 200 euros deuxième raison
mouvement des gilet jaune a obtenu des
choses il ya eu 12 milliards qui ont été
mis sur la table et beaucoup de ceux qui
ont participé estiment qu'ils n'ont pas
eu pour leur argent et que ça c'est
transforme ça s'est terminé un peu en
queue de poisson ils sont pas c'est
comme quand vous perdez un conflit
social veut repartir en grève ce n'est
pas forcément évident et puis la
troisième raison c'est que on à la
présidentielle qui approche et autant
les français ont très massivement
séché si je puis dire ou fait l'école
buissonnière au moment des élections
locales plus de 65 % d'abstention
régionales je pense qu'on est encore
dans une culture très vème république
avec un monarque républicain qui sait
parfaitement peut-être même trop couler
dans ses habits là et c'est le syndrome
de ce que j'appelle aller me chercher le
patron c'est à dire que les textes à dix
nous le rendez vous c'est tous les cinq
ans on va lire le boss est donc plutôt
que se remette sur les ronds points on a
rendez vous dans six mois où là on va
régler les comptes et on aura en
exprimera ce qu'on a sur le sur le pont
mais encore une fois soyons prudents
c'est pour n'est pas à l'abri de
d'un retour de flamme nicolas chapuis
justement sur ces sur une colère sur des
braises voilà d'une de cette colère des
gilets jaunes est ce qu est ce qu elle
s'exprime en filigrane dans l'est dans
les portraits de francs dans les
fragments de france que vous proposez
alors elle s'exprime pareil que j'ai en
tout cas je serais très simple sur la
sur la capacité à prédire les gilet
jaune même le renseignement territoriale
n'avait rien vu venir donc
donc donc je me garderai bien de faire
des pronostics je pense qu'il ya quand
même un élément qu'on mesure passé
l'effet du quoi qu'il en coûte il n'y a
énormément de gens qui nous ont dit à
travers les reportages que sans les
aides de l'état et bien aujourd'hui il
aurait mis la clé sous la porte qu'ils
n'auraient pas tenu qu'ils auraient et
et que 7,7
l'état qui a joué son rôle dans ces
moments là avec quand même un transfert
d'argent public dans la pole directement
des gens dans des proportions qu'on n'a
jamais connu historiquement
est quand même un élément qui est
absolument majeur le deuxième élément
qui fait que à mon avis ces braises
lasson sont pas forcément pas rentrer là
ce n'est pas la même dynamique
qu'à l'époque c'est que la france se
relève quand même d'une épreuve qu'on a
du mal à nous on a du mal encore à me à
mesurer on peut prendre tous les tous
les éléments statistiques
essayez de raconter la france dans tous
et dans tous ses aspects et monsieur
fort qu elle le fait très bien dans son
livre il ya une dimension très
personnelle là dans la crise qui a été
vécu les gens ont perdu des proches les
gens ont traversé des situations
d'isolement ont traversé une rupture de
leurs liens sociaux et tout ça on sait
pas du tout encore ce que ça va produire
et ses ferments là sont très différents
d'une crise sociale purs sur le modèle
du prix de l'énergie où on connaît les
ressorts on sait on cerne on sait ce
qu'il en est cette crise vraiment haut
de ces gens qui ont traversé cette
épreuve là qui ont vu leurs liens
sociaux se détruire parfois se
reconstruire des nouvelles solidarités
des anciennes qui sont mortes tout ça
c'est des choses dont on va voir les
effets dans les années qui viennent et
que je serais bien en peine de de
mesurer à l'heure actuelle est de dire
ça va produire tel ou tel est faite il
ya une autre question qui est
intéressante c'est la perception d'un
déclin français je vais m'appuyer sur
cette enquête annuelle fractures
françaises on est dans des thématiques
qui reprennent les vôtres à ces enquêtes
ipsos sopra steria donc sur cette année
2000 21 75% des français qui pensent que
la france est en déclin s'étaient 86 %
en 2016 donc c'est à la tendance est
également
intéressante françoise gatel
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que la
crise sanitaire a peut-être atténuer ce
sentiment d'une france en déclin s'est
recueillie a eu dans les premières
semaines cette impression qu on était un
peu les derniers de la classe et puis ça
s'est atténuée au fur et à mesure que la
crise avancé est ce que vous ressentez
ça vaut aussi alors je crois que le quoi
qu'il en coûte ça a été dit a été un
amortisseur
c'est à dire que les gens ils des peurs
vertigineuse que c'était la vie qui
s'arrêtait l'avait économique la vie
sociale mais on ne savait pas où on
allait donc effectivement moi je ressens
comme vous le sentiment où les gens
disent tu aurais pu être pire et ce que
le gouvernement fait c'est bien ça veut
pas dire pour autant que voilà ils
voteront pour le prêt d'un an et public
ou qu'on n'en a pas des émeutes mais
c'est vrai et quand même temps je pense
que ça renvoie les uns et les autres
sans doute d'une manière
individuelle et diffuse à inventer un
avenir différent et que les gens
pouvaient rêver d'un mode de vie qui
était interrogé par la crise on vend au
sortir à un peu moins on partira en
vacances près de chez soi et pas à
l'étranger on essaie de protéger ses
enfants et je pense toutefois qu'il n'ya
des territoires qu'ils ressentent un
déclin terrible enfin dans le livre
jambes pour qu elle le décrit très bien
des endroits du territoire qu'on était
très prospère et pour des raisons x ou y
eu soyez des conversions qui ont tardé
soit il ya eu 1 le jeu d'acteur il n'y a
pas eu d'entente et un moment tout ce
qui faisait la prospérité économique est
derrière la solidarité sociale et le
modèle social tout ça c'est parti les
gens sentent que le monde de leurs
mondes proches leur échappe et qu'on est
dans une mondialisation qui les dévorent
donc je pense qu'il ya enfin c'est pas
je pensé qu' il ya des endroits où c'est
extrêmement difficile et la seule chose
qui rattache de manière très modestes
comme un filet qui empêche on va dire le
désespoir total c'est effectivement des
actions qui se font dans les territoires
parce qu'il ya des élus quand même 35
mille communes dans des territoires
parfois très difficiles où des gens se
présentent aux élections et se bat pour
construire un avenir travaille avec des
associations et moi je pense que une
reconstruction qui serait qui se fera je
crois pas au mot réconciliation
on va inventer un autre monde mais fou
qu'il parte des territoires au lieu de
croire qu'on va avoir un sauveur au mois
de juin et que de paris on va réinventer
la france moi je crois pas si on va y
arriver effectivement la tradition de la
5ème fait qu'on attend le sauveur bref
faut bien dissocier
sur les villes puisque sk une
accélération du phénomène c'est à ce
sentiment qu'une ville est à la mode
peut-être que ça a été d'ailleurs
accélérée par le télétravail des faits
commis et une autre peut se sentir comme
ça très rapidement mises de côté un peu
un peu délaissé la mondialisation est
effarant plaignants oui non c'est à dire
la prend combien de temps quand ça
dépend comment ça peut être très rapide
si vous avez une mono industrie qui
ferment dans une ville moyenne ou dans
l'est de la france une autre
mono-industrie quitter la mono industrie
de la caserne que la fin de la
conscription donc on a des villes
entières qui se sont jamais remis du
départ des régiments
sinon le souvent le processus est quand
même plus long est ce qu'on essaye avec
jean-laurent cassely de montrer dans ce
livre c'est qu'il ya une nouvelle carte
de la désirabilité des territoires alors
christophe qui lui avait parlé des
métropoles et de la france périphérique
mais il faut ajouter tous les littoraux
sont du côté des gagnants et puis posco
vide tous ces territoires périphériques
soient desservies par le tgv soit
distance raisonnable dont une à deux
heures des grandes métropoles et qui
font objet aujourd'hui de lieu de
villégiature pour des populations qui
peuvent se dire voilà on va voir un
jardin le barbecue peut-être un bout de
piscine si on a un peu les moyens et on
va trouver une qualité de vie et donc
les français sont très conscients je
pense de cette nouvelle hiérarchie des
territoires ce qu'on appelait la france
triple à celle qui instagram abl
souviens quand un confinement on
envoyait voilà je suis là à regarder
pendant que vous travaillez moi je suis
en train de bosser depuis ma terrasse
sur la mer etc si on fait une liste des
villes instagram abl
et donc on a parlé on a parlé donc du
coup de la revanche des villes moyennes
posco vidre je pense que c'est en partie
vrai certaines mais il faut quand même
un certain nombre d'attributs c'est à
dire être desservis par
le rail et de manière assez rapide être
comme dans un endroit où il fait assez
beau et des ombres qui sont souvent un
peu touristique et donc c'est quand même
le sud les littoraux et puis les zones
qui sont
j'allais dire agréable en périphérie pas
trop lointaine des grandes métropoles et
donc certaines villes moyennes vont
tirer leur épingle du jeu on le voit
déjà des prix de l'immobilier qui
augmente des télétravailleurs qui
viennent s'installer et puis d'autres
qui vont hélas rester davantage à
l'écart et où
l'hôpital et le carrefour ou leclerc du
coin seront les continueront d'être les
principaux employeurs parce que le reste
de l'activité économique a disparu
la question du modèle français ou d'un
projet de société commun c'est aussi ce
qui ressort un peu de 2 voilà de vos
projets alain et à l'eau de votre doudou
du projet du monde et je voudrais qu'on
réécoute ya un extrait de l'émission
c'était au mois de septembre dernier 27
septembre avec les céistes david djaïz
qui publie le nouveau modèle français il
se pose la question de la façon de
réinventer l'état un état peut être un
nouvel état formé au service des
initiatives locales écoulée il ya un
truc qui est fondamentale en france
depuis des siècles c'est l'état est
effectivement cet état moi je fais le
concert qui s'est bureaucratisé qui
s'est alourdie qu'il a un peu dévié de
ce rôle d'aiguillon qu'il a eu pendant
plusieurs siècles il faut retrouver ce
rôle et moi je crois que aujourd'hui
l'état il doit plus être simplement dans
la verticalité surplombant dans
l'étouffement en quelque sorte de la
société mais il doit être la vigie il se
passe des choses extraordinaires dans
notre société dans notre économie à des
villes il ya des entreprises et des
associations qui sont dans l'innovation
trouver ce qui marche le
le partage et 200 exemple à loos en
gohelle on est passé du noir au vert on
a fermé les puits de mine on a
reconstruit une nouvelle économie à
kingersheim on a inventé de la
démocratie participative dans la bio
valley dans la drôme il se passe des
choses extraordinaires il ya des succès
industriel à vire dans le calvados par
exemple ou à figeac dans le lot l'état
son rôle ça doit être quoi c'est d'aller
voir ce qui se fait de mieux et de
donner aux autres les moyens de
développer ces innovations quand ils les
uns auraient spontanément françoise
gatel mettre l'état au service est team
local ça vous parle forcément ah oui oui
je suggère un président d'un public de
le prendre comme ulysse exactement ce
qu'on a dit me dis sincèrement moi je
crois on voit bien aujourd'hui que
l'état il est totalement qu'ils osent y
on l'a vu pendant la crise la crise
commis de l'état s'occupe de tout et
décide de tout donc il s'attire des tas
d'ennuis puisque tout le monde lui dit
qu'il fait mal les choses moi je pense
qu'il doit se recentrer sur des
compétences régaliennes la sécurité et
il laisse les territoires
s'organiser il les accompagne leur
facilite la vie est ce que pour avoir
été maire pendant 16 ans comme tous les
maires de france j'ai vécu des réunions
mais c'étaient des cauchemars vous
arrivez vous à bien un sujet une
question que certains pellet un problème
vous aviez 15 fonctionnaires autour de
vous qui à madame le maire c'est une
excellente idée maintenant ça va pas
être possible
donc vous rentrez chez vous puis vous
retournez ou 10 tonnes on line moi il
faut que je trouve une solution ce que
mes concitoyens navale et donc il faut
qu'on se mette tous et les tailles en
mode jeu résout les problèmes parce que
les élus se sont il le dit des
inventeurs de possibles ils sont
capables de vous inventer des trucs que
les fonctionnaires ne peuvent pas
imaginer ci comprennent pas que son
terrain nous on est obligé d'inventer
parce qu'il faut que ça marche les élus
les artisans les abris parce que les les
associations
il ya un écosystème qui se fait les élus
travaillent avec les entreprises et les
associations et tout ça ça fait un truc
un milieu extrêmement favorable où
poussent des idées et des inventions
mais vous restez sur les élus vous savez
qu'il ya aussi la thèse contraire contre
concernant cette crise sanitaire il ya
aussi l'idée de se dire finalement un
seul capitaine dans le bateau ça n'a pas
si mal fonctionné et d'ailleurs on a vu
qu'en italie et en espagne ils ont re
centraliser la gestion de la crise parce
qu'au début les provinces autonomes et
les régions se tirer la bourre ce qu'on
peut dire vulgairement ils sont aperçus
que ça marchait mieux avec un seul
capitaine est ce que vous ne craignez
pas que cet après crise sanitaire ça
soit aussi la fin d'une certaine volonté
de décentraliser davantage alors j'ai un
droit de réponse est important alors
vous dites pas le contraire le mois je
pense qu'à la fin on va mettre d'accord
célia on a bien vu comment les élus il
inventait des choses ils ont créé des
centres de vaccination ils ont trouvé
des masques enfin ils ont fait des trucs
miraculeux nous ce qu'on a demandé c'est
un commandement unique c'est-à-dire
quand sur la crise sanitaire vous avez
un directeur de rs qui parlent pas au
préfet du département et qui va chercher
ses ordres directement ministère et que
quand vous êtes en pleine crise vous
avez dit question avant que le directeur
de la rs il est la réponse à chanceler
jeu de voiles agences régionales de
santé que faire ces gens dit enfin mr 60
buts là il nous faut un pilote dans
l'avion quand il ya une crise il faut un
chef de commando c'est le préfet qui
doit voir autour de lui tous les
services de l'état et en interlocuteur
les élus voilà mais on ne dit pas la
santé res une compétence régalienne
nicolas chapuis qu'est ce qui réunit les
français
qui ressort est ce qu'il ya malgré tout
une valeur commune un tronc commun
projet commun les français on a
rencontré encore une fois je vais pas
dire les français parce que sa vie est
un matériau 6 mai les français pour
beaucoup d'entre eux sont assez fiers de
leur pays de l'endroit où ils sont en
tout cas de leurs de leurs territoires à
eux ça ça ressort ça ressort assez
fortement et peut-être aussi du
comportement comme un pendant cette
crise sanitaire est ce que vous diriez
ça est-ce que ça participe d'une fierté
partagée en tout cas la france a tenu et
ça c'est ça je pense qu'on l'a pas assez
souligné médiatiquement c'est à dire
qu'on a beaucoup fait sur les problèmes
et c'était normal et on a raconté tout
ce qui n'allait pas et on n'a pas
raconté aussi tout ce qui est bien aller
pendant cette crise et tout ce qui a
fonctionné et finalement le raconte un
peu a posteriori novak le match est
terminé on attribuer des bons points à
droite à gauche et on n'a pas assez
raconté qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont qui ont qui ont marché
moi je rajouterais juste quelque chose à
ce que disait la sénatrice ya les élus
locaux mais à travers le reportage en
fait ce qui ressort c'est que la france
elle tient beaucoup sur les épaules de
quelques personnes ya beaucoup de
territoires qui est pas forcément des
élus ou des associations il ya beaucoup
de territoires qu'ils tiennent parce
qu'il ya une ou deux personnes qui
localement fond des choses tiennent un
lieu qui permettent de sociabiliser
beaucoup de gens et que s'il ya des gens
on raconte notamment dans les reportages
un couple de retraités qui tient le
milieu associatif contrat en sologne et
qui tient sur ses épaules en fait la vie
sociale et la vie associative de
beaucoup de gens qui cherchent à passer
la main aujourd'hui ils ont plus de
soixante dix ans et il y arrive pas il
trouve pas des gens qui veulent prendre
leur relais et donc ils veulent pas
arrêter parce qu'ils veulent pas que
tout s'effondre sur et en france on a
dans tous les territoires des gens comme
ça sur lesquels repose énormément de
choses et ça tient finalement à peu
personnes et a un peu de choses et je
pense que si l'étape d'une façon d'une
aider ces gens là pas forcément
directement mais mais mais si la société
française peut aider ces gens là à tenir
d'autant plus c'est je pense qu'on aura
fait déjà un grand pas jérôme fourquet à
un projet de société est ce que parce
que la france que vous écrivez elle est
tellement kaléidoscopique on se dit
qu'est ce qui nous réunit alors un
projet de société je sais pas si c
un projet de société en tout cas ce
qu'on appelle dans le livre nous il ya
un idéal qui est très majoritaire c'est
ce qu'on appelle le modèle plaza en
hommage les agents immobiliers le club
de france et ce contre quoi la ministre
du logement récemment a dit qu'il
fallait arrêter c'est une aberration
écologique donc on peut débattre là
dessus un sur l'étalement urbain mais on
voit nous 56% des français vivent en
maison et 75% aspirent à y vivre et
encore plus madame la sénatrice peut en
parler dans son département depuis la
crise du coc vide et donc il ya très
forts investissements sur ce cocon cette
sphère individuelle c'est le vincent
colbert qui par la civilisation de la
société du cocon et ça c'est quelque
chose qui fédère énormément alors c'est
un truc très individualiste mais ça
fédère beaucoup et j'en veux pour preuve
par exemple le fait que à bas bruit on
voit arriver dans toute une série de
zones pavillonnaires en périphérie des
grandes métropoles progressivement des
familles qui sont issus de l'immigration
et qui ont à bas bruit a entamé leur
parcours résidentiel et beaucoup dans
beaucoup de territoires c'est un peu
moins le cas maintenant parce que la
france est très construite mais en
beaucoup d'endroits on disait à un
moment c'est une très grande fierté en
famille j'ai fait construire j'ai fait
construire ce sujet voilà est donc là
c'était l'aboutissement c'est parce que
c'est comme si c'est ce que vous dites
c'est presque un vieux un vieux rêve
français il faut crier terre il est là
l'as vitré
ille à mon ami retrouver une deuxième
jeunesse avec le co vide alors ça va
poser des questions puisque ce modèle il
s'appuie à la fois sur la maison
individuelle et aussi sur la voiture et
voyez que la crise et gilet jaune comme
la levée de boucliers face à l'as dit la
déclaration de la ministre croit que
quand on touche les deux piliers de ce
modèle c'est très très urticants en
france merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je renvoie
évidemment à la lecture du du monde à
ces fragments de france et puis jérôme
fourquet la france
sous nos yeux c'est avec jean-laurent
cassely essai publié au seuil voilà je
vous donne rendez vous demain